[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
talk about
ancient climate change ancient as in
during
the time we've been human and maybe even
a little bit of our
pre-human ancestors and what
impact does climate change have on our
diets
what did they eat and was it good for
them
okay i i don't have any expertise in
this at all
other than the fact that i eat food so
uh we brought in an expert for this but
before we introduce
that expert let me show you my co-host
for today
matt curtin man welcome back hey thanks
neil how are you dude
dude are you still doing that show most
likely could be science
it's it's probably science probably you
know i don't know why i
cannot remember that it's it's it's a
it's amazing you're so good at
remembering so many facts and that one
seems to slip your mind every time
i don't i i don't know if you saw by the
way my uh
i don't you got a shout out from my
co-host on jeopardy last month oh really
okay uh andy my the other probably
science host
had a he did all right he he he did us
proud
he was competing yeah and uh
one of his anecdotes one of his little
uh bits of information was about the
podcast and dropped the fact that you
were at one point in his living room
as a friend of the show well excellent
excellent so now i gotta remember it
exactly okay
probably science very good very good so
matt and i will welcome today a uh
someone i met
through someone else at the american
museum of natural history
which it's an institution yes we have
astrophysicists there
but mostly they're like people who care
about
like cultures anthropology animal
kingdom
and uh so there's a whole other place
where i get some sort of osmotic
thoughts about just what's going on in
the rest of
the scientific universe and we have with
us tina
ludeki did i say that right tina almost
but no american cancer don't you better
no america again
yes excellent excellent we have you on
this show
today because you are a geochemist and
you're you're dialing in
from germany you're geochemist and you
focus on
um reconstructing
paleo ecosystems
pillow ecosystem paleo diets paleo
everything basically
yep so you you're you're a you're
sherlock holmes
of their lives okay yes i take that
okay because because they didn't have
books for you to read about what they
did
so you have to like piece together the
artifacts
and reconstruct what was going on uh in
in
in in everyday everyday occurrences
right is that
that's what you do basically yes yeah
okay so
your current title is your read my notes
here you're
a postdoc at the sneckenberg
biodiversity and climate research center
and frankfort germany excellent
excellent and you're also affiliated
with the university of oxford
over in england and the max planck
institute for chemistry
excellent in maine mainz germany
how did i do that is correct i get a
b-plus
you do yes well it's difficult with all
those things i'm just
about to switch jobs so it's yeah it's
not from
switch jobs we just worked on this no no
from sankenberg from my main affiliation
i would say from zankenberg to the max
bank institute so
oh gosh you were shifting okay you have
everything don't change job
titles because then like you know we
worked hard on this one
for our sake so so tell me
about your research because we we were
at a
gathering of museum colleagues and
that's when i learned more fully what
you were into and i said whoa
we got to get that on star talk and so
tell me
what your research entails and how do
you
how do you piece together what ancient
people ate
so basically my main research lies in
the reconstruction of
four to one million year old south
africa paleo landscapes
so a time frame we can't even usually
cope if you don't have insulin
four million euros one million years old
this are my oldest samples yes
well my older standards are 12 million
years but i will not talk about these
here
so human evolution there it's a really
interesting time between
four and one million years old because a
lot of things happened you had a lot of
different hominin taxa that lived
like they coexisted so they lived in the
same habitat
okay we say hominid taxa okay so you
mean
so we are humans well let me back up
just
tell me if i got this right when we
think of rodents we can think of
rats and mice and dozens of other
species within the rodent family
right so are we in the hominid family
but we only have one species is that is
that correct
in the harmony we only have one species
they
they terms are changing there quite
often but in the hominin
sp um taxa we are the only remaining
species
so okay so you're going back to it
you're going back to a time
where there were more than what we call
humans
as hominids walking around so we have
homo and astrolopyticus
um
for example they all co-existed at some
point in time
and space possibly they couldn't
okay so so in the the
the hominid family or hope you said the
the name the word changed just so i can
be yeah hominid is basically that would
nowadays also mean
um great apes like orangutans or
gorillas chimps and everything and all
their ancestors
and harm and men i knew it
matt i knew an ape one time and i
thought he was a great ape
i thought he was a good guy
i i'm still i i i'm still sort of
coming to terms with the fact that there
were so many of them living at the same
time because
you know i i'm picturing the picture
that we've all seen of the sort of uh
the the going from this to the uh
you know a lot of people are listening
to the audio version so they won't see
what i'm doing but you can imagine some
linear sequences
and then i'm standing more and more
there we go and then you start crouching
back over again
over your computer yes okay yeah which
is what i'm saying
but yeah it's very important tina you're
saying it was not linear so there are
times when
multiple uh homo species were
co-existing and that's hard to picture
because look how tribalized we are
just as one species imagine if there are
other
hominids walking around i mean i can't
even picture what we how we treat each
other and we call it even not a family
tree really anymore but many people like
to call it a family bush basically
because there are so many branches and
then of course new species evolved
others
went extinct so you have to come and go
of many species
over the times two of them became
president one tried
so i so so this is before what we would
consider
today as anatomically um modern human
accurate humans modern humans you would
say yes yes
modern humans right okay okay so now so
this is the paleo era
oh that's cool so now what did you find
so so basically i i try to reconstruct
how
paleo environment changed so how did the
landscape the habitat and everything
change over time
and with that like how did the hominins
in a change
especially their diet which is the main
driver for
evolution of course like the energy you
put in you can use for something
basically
so and as a geochemist my favorite tools
are stable isotope systems
so i work with isotopes which means i
basically different isotopes of
different elements can like fingerprint
um different settings different
environmental proxies or what somebody
ate
so i look at carbon oxygen and nitrogen
and for example carbon isotope systems
can tell me what kind of plant
was growing on a site so if i look into
a soil for example what kind of plant
was growing on the site
or what kind of plant an animal ate or
animal also early human for example ate
so i think i think whole foods now has
an isotope section
[Laughter]
i only buy the heavy stuff yeah
it does sound very much like something
that's represented by a glowing image in
an average well that too yeah
the glowing aisle these are the isotopes
if you want to totally mimic
i don't think that actually exists yet
that would be fun to just like for
example water what it tells us about
what kind of
um water is present so oxygen in the
water um as
the delta 180 values we would call shows
us for example is the water from a small
puddle of leftover
like um yeah leftover rain basically
that evaporated and you only have a
little bit of
of um water remaining in a super arid
environment for example
or is it from a river or a big lake that
is present all year round
in amazing okay so this is deep so what
you're saying is
um again i'm only repeating to make sure
i
understand and um so
so oxygen as we know uh
it has sort of eight protons and eight
neutrons in its nucleus
so we think of of happy oxygen as
oxygen 16 right that is the one we
learned in school yes
that's the one we learned about in
school and then
you can find versions of oxygen that
have
extra neutrons one of them is uh has
eight neutrons and eight electrons and
ten neutrons this would be oxygen 18
right so now if you make water because
hydrogen doesn't care it just cares that
it's oxygen
right so hydrogen binds with the oxygen
some of them will be bound with oxygen
18 others with oxygen
16 and now the water is just standing
there and
you have slow evaporation so is it
correct
to think that the lighter water molecule
will evaporate
preferentially relative to the heavier
water molecule
exactly so that standing water will
ultimately
have more oxygen 18 water molecules than
fresh water that just came in is that is
that right exactly
and then if you for example drink from
that water
and i pull your tooth out and measure it
and i can see on this
you just do this i do that all the time
i'm not visiting your lab what she's
doing let's say let's say one says hey
you might not be here anymore and you
get fossilized
and i don't i want to die first and then
you can pull my teeth out okay and
in four million years i will come and i
will find your tooth and your tooth is
so
resistant to digenesis so to doing
processes as fossilization basically
that your isotopic fingerprint is still
present in your tooth
so four million years later or even 20
million year later if preservation is
well
i can see what kind of water you drink
so did you live
in new york and you drank from the
hudson river or did you live
in the savannah and you have a tiny
puddle of
just a little bit of standing water full
of mosquitoes and bugs
wait a minute so you had so you already
you can identify
hudson water which isotope is that
[Laughter]
okay now we get really deep so it's i
mean you can
forensic um is using that quite often
that you you
can with isotopes you can actually see
where
a product came from in soil and in
something i was
i would not be able to right now have 10
samples and pick out which one is hudson
river
and which one is the east river or
anything but all i'm saying is i can see
what kind of water it has
like um if it's yeah if it's evaporative
water that is like with a high effective
evaporation
or if it's in a lush green landscape
basically water that is available
all over the place which is of course
for our human evolution
quite interesting if those um
if those early hominins had a lot of
water stress and they had to migrate
long distances or they
i don't know they couldn't find any
water and would maybe die off
in the drought or if there was love
about this is that you are taking
you're you're speaking as a chemist but
you're applying your chemistry
background
to paleontology i am i am a geologist
actually
and i put a cam like i i have a i'm a
geosciences
by training as my undergrad and then
then i focus on geochemistry a long time
ago like
a long time in my time frame not in
geology
the last 10 years in the last 10 years
so
when we hear the paleo diet which is
showing up
it rears its head every now and then and
my first thought is you know paleo
people
didn't really live much past 30. do i
want to eat the way they do
why is that something we should so tell
me what is the
what is the i don't want to ask a health
food person i want to ask you
yes what the hell is a paleo diet and
that is a question
we there is no paleo diet i think
payload diet i think so if you think
about i just talked about
three to four million years time span
and
um early hominins that evolved
that um lived in different areas and
different like
continents basically and younger times
they expanded to europe and everything
so they had really different
resources um available and everything so
if somebody talks about the paleo diet i
always think
how paleo do you want to go like how far
back do you want to go do you want to
eat like in
a solo pedicles three million years ago
or
i don't know neanderthal which is not
that
long ago but lived in a very different
um a very different environment
nevertheless
so for me it's always really difficult
to understand the paleo diet
and if i then read up on it which of
course i should because i get this
question sometimes
um then i'm always thinking another
point is you can't get a paleolithic
diet
so we modified our food so widely like
the
the um of course like um plants but also
animals were
were manipulated basically if you think
about a banana for example it used to
look very very different now we have
those beautiful bananas but they can't
even reproduce
they don't have seeds anymore they're
all cuttings from the same plant
so and while a meal that for our
ancestors
was healthy because they were running
around in the savannah they were hunter
and gatherers they were
outside all day long they didn't
necessarily became that old
but they were really healthy they had a
good attrition they
um they were vital
they thrived usually and everything and
then we started this agricultural
lifestyle basically
which was in a way awesome for us
because
it was possible to it made our
population explode basically
suddenly you had crops you could
maintain food you could store it often
if you're at one place and everything
but of course then people were also
getting
more obese they had cavities they got
sickness by living together in close
approximately with animals for example
and all of this we even had to invent a
word to describe when everybody gets
sick
from having getting a disease from
animal pandemic
very trafficking we got to take a quick
break but when we come back
more of tina
uh who's our paleo expert in the house
and
matt kirschner we'll see you guys in
just a moment
we're back star talk we're talking about
the paleo diet and paleo climate
with tina ludecky did i get that right
tina
almost almost okay let's keep working on
it
and of course matt kirschen as my
co-host always good to have you back
matt
lovely to be here we're thinking about
the paleo
paleo uh tina what do i call that period
of time
paleo
we have lots of different terms a lot of
different spans
okay all right i'll go with it i'll take
them all
and so in there you're thinking about
not only climate but environment in
which
our ancestors lived
and so i'm intrigued because
when people say i want to go on a paleo
diet and you're telling us that
different
places had different diets so there is
no one
paleo diet and so
you are figuring this out from your
scientific
investigations you told us about the
oxygen
and an isotope of oxygen
carbon also we all know carbon-14 right
that's a famous
carbon isotope what other chemistry do
you bring to the table
so maybe you notice that so far i only
talked about the plant-based diet right
so
with with carbon i can look at what kind
of plants were eaten
and um nitrogen is actually a great tool
to reconstruct the meat-based part of
the diet so it was made
consum consumed by the individualized
sample
and we see with each trophic level
basically the delta 15 n values of 15 to
14
n would increase and so this would be a
nitrogen
15 which is the isotope of the
the happy nitrogen at 14 which is seven
protons seven neutrons okay so you look
at the ratio of those two and what does
that tell you
exactly so this usually tells me trophic
level so was meat consumed or not were
we in a level with like the heavy voice
basically or did we enter
a carnivore guilt for example and here
it's interesting so this system is well
established i mean there
is always loose ends about it but it's
well established but it was only
possible to measure actually
on samples that were like up to 150
000 years old basically so something
underthoughts were measured for example
but 150 000 years and i just said i want
to look at
millions of years so i was always
bothered by the fact that i could
reconstruct
an ancients like in really early
hormones i could
reconstruct the plant-based diet but i
could not
look at the meat part of the diet and we
have stone tools we have cut marks which
are like
three and a half million years old or
something so cut marks on fossilized
bones
so we have indicators that meat
consumers started quite early in
hominins but
no it was not possible to actually look
into this
all right so you're inferring correctly
no doubt that you see bones
of animals that have fossilized bones of
animals that have markings on them
indicating that someone was hacking at
them cutting perhaps cutting away meat
yeah so with some kind of with a tool
and
why would you do that unless you were
going to eat the animal but that's the
question who exactly did it
who i mean we don't find an
asthalopeticus with a stone tool and a
cut mark bone in his hand basically
so we don't have direct evidence who
actually did it so i was really
frustrated about the fact that
that it was not able that i was not able
to reconstruct the meat part of the diet
and then finally this year only actually
basically i
was able to establish a method to
measure
nitrogen on fossil teeth which are
digestibly
um robust so they are preserved over
time and
um with colleagues from the mpic and
especially genophyllic letters so i was
able to now i see max planche
exactly and now finally for the first
time ever we are able to have direct
evidence of meat consumption or we can
have it if we measure
um if we measure um different hominins
of which hominins started when
to include meat in their diet and what
that possibly means like for the success
of our species for example
or the extinction of other species
so this would have been the beginning
once they figured out how to eat meat
matt do you think i'm right here this is
this is this is the
birth of vegetarians because they wanna
they don't wanna eat them
yeah i mean i i i don't eat meat and i
would have been very unspecial in the
before
carnival time so it's well what would
you even talk about how would you
distinguish yourself and if you had to
become vegan would you make how would
you make yourself
yeah they're vegans where are the vegans
right we haven't invented vegans yet
we basically have if you take away
breast milk so of course
early hominins were also not yet eating
or
drinking milk in when once they were
older
so after weaning after taking away the
breast milk they would also be
vegan you would basically have a diet
like a
typical habit right so what you're
saying is
some paleo diets from in your
range of food consumption that you found
would
be classified as vegan correct
right so so this idea that paleo diet is
just meat and
no potatoes uh that's just a misnomer
yes in a way yes yeah you don't there is
our stomachs and our guts for example
are not adapted
to just eat meat we can't have a diet
like a lion has nowadays
we just can't so we are omnivorous we
have to eat plant parts
and as we know as matt just said he is
vegetarian and i used to be vegetarian
for 10 years and i'm fine
so we actually see this is actually
where we see that now
how do you know how do you know you're
fine
actually i feel okay
i didn't die you could be completely
different now
had you not you don't know you are just
new at any moment
now actually matt's collected questions
for us from our fan base so this is sort
of a hybrid
cosmic queries but we still have so much
more we want to learn from
you directly but matt let me throw on a
question yeah so i've got a bunch of
questions from patreon
uh first of all josh v asks
what kind of evidence is considered when
determining what an ancient tribe of
people
regularly consumed are there remains of
food from tens of thousands of years ago
interesting yeah can food get fossilized
the way other things can
like you see can you see a whole table
setting fossilized in place
you can if you think about pompeii for
example pompeo
like the volcano eruption you have ashes
over there so
first of all i have to say i really like
the word regularly in there
oh i hate it i like it i'm not sure but
if i think about
my like if my study to look at
stable isotopes i have one point in time
from one individual but it's actually
really interesting to see
what the whole tribe would eat and what
it would regularly eat
so um so the actual study of food
material as you said it's super
difficult because most of the food decay
we know that
but however if you have um burned a meal
so by accidental
cooking accident in your little cave or
something then material like
seeds and pollen and grains can be
preserved
over super long time scales basically
indefinitely if you have the right
environment for them
so um and in these time in these and
these plant remains you can actually see
for example if a crop was wild or
cultivated already
by the structure they have and um that
for example dated like the
earliest rice domestication of rice to
like
11 and a half thousand years ago
in china for example but of course that
is
still not the long timescale we look at
because you have to find those ashes
basically with the food in it
but then there are lots of different fun
things for example
coprolites are really interesting i
don't know if that's that
coprolites what is that fossilized feces
oh okay keep the other name for it
sorry i asked so yeah
and it's really interesting for example
and i'm thinking about messel
the mesopit here in germany it's it's 47
year
million year old using a pip basically
and you do have wonderfully preserved
coprolites where you can of course do
different chemical or
other analyzers within to see what the
animal ate
digested and then left behind
basically yeah i think there's a good
scene in the original
jurassic park film where one of the
scientists was an expert in
studying the the feces and so
the animal keeps moving and it's still
kind of steaming right
and then it reach in and we're all just
kind of looking at that
but it was i'd forgotten that yeah i
mean it doesn't stink anymore
42 million years later that's a good
part i don't i don't believe you
it depends on me but then we also have
of course a few
um like think about human like the
oldest food
and there you have for example the
oldest bread is like
14 400 years old in yodan
so that is even older than the first the
start of
the agriculture so you made it with wild
cereals
and one of the oldest thing i can think
about right now is um
is wine so in georgia um
wine was produced 8 000 years ago
so i think it's yeah it's six thousand
years that's just just outside of
just outside of atlanta i think in
georgia that's where they did that okay
the other one the other oh oh okay
there's a merc
so this is america i heard 5801 bc was a
particularly good vintage
really sunny really nice but it's quite
expensive yeah
so so this so you have a lot of access
points into
what we did for me which is the really
young past basically again if i think
about millions of years ago it's it
becomes i mean coprolites as i said or
you can have the
um dental calculus which can have like
pollen or like even dna structures of
whatever you ate
um but of course something like the the
wine or the bread or
some super old cheese from egypt for
example that is of course something what
i consider
just yesterday uh in in another
you know 100 000 years or so your
descendants
will look at the uh north america and
what was once the united states and
they'll find
perfectly intact twinkies
don't like burgers also stay like
mcdonald's burger like forever
so i believe so yeah so whether it can
be preserved
is a whole other thing because it
changes whether it was preserved is
another
sort of effort yes to make that happen
matt give me another question
let's go look this uh comes from leslie
goodwill but actually from leslie's
daughter trinity
who asks how does the change in diet
parentheses cooked food impact upon
human development
can this be applied to other animals so
tina that question reminds me that today
among the many
sort of paths of diets that people take
one of them is the raw food diet all
right
and so i never really understood that
because i think the food tastes better
if you cook it
but this i think this is a brilliant
question
from trinity i guess ask that yeah yes i
agree it's very interesting so if you
cook food you you break up for example
the starches
in in potatoes or something into easily
like
available energy rich sugars so they are
you still have the same stuff in your
potato but it's easily accessible for
your body and you
can actually use it and so
when cooked you have a higher energy
output of
the same the same food product basically
so if you think about early hominins
which
how like they have this brains that grew
over time and they developed um they
have lots of
um babies and fetuses and everything so
you would think about you have
access to food that has higher energy
basically
so you spend much less time of actually
eating
collecting i mean you spend time on
preparing food and pounding and cutting
and
cooking of course but you would then
have more of it
so you have more time for social
behavior for grooming
um i just think about i i was with um
with primatologists in mozambique in the
gurgaons national park and they
they look they um study baboons and they
took me a day on a field trip basically
and i was
giving a shout with the checklist and
you would see what an animal
and baboon does all day long and i had
this checklist and
at eight and eight and eight it just
sits there and eats it has not
that much time for anything else so for
us we then had we had lots of energy to
actually
um change our morphology basically to
grow bigger brains to have more kids
did i hear tina correctly matt didn't
she just say that had the baboon
been given higher energy food it would
have time to like build spaceships
and and you know and yeah create a whole
civilization
i think that's what she just said right
there i think so and that also worries
me because
uh i'm still in lockdown and i'm just
eating and eating and eating so i'm
pretty worried about being overtaken by
the baboons right now
so tina what you're saying is what
percentage of your life do you spend
tracking down food to eat then that's
all you do
for your survival there's no free time
there's no leisure time there's no
you can't think up algebra you know
there's no there's no luxury
that doesn't contribute to your own
survival and of course and
the own survival is of course also given
by having kids
and um we still benefit from this
cooking of meat if you think about
um we only breastfeed for a year in
average or something like this
and humans modern humans can have kids
easily
a year and a half apart um so my sister
my older sister is only one and a half
years older than i am and that is
quite okay and normal if you look at
chimps they're usually five years apart
but we have the advantage we cook our
food we can mush it we have all this
more energy energy in it and
then you would you are able to feed your
kid
much earlier fruit like mashed up
potatoes and carrots and not just give
it a potato oil carrot in a hand and let
it munch on it
so this actually helped our species to
evolve and to be successful as well
i think what you're really saying is it
helped our species to get fat
much earlier than others that as well
as well we're going to take another
quick break when we come back more
of this uh installment of star talk
the paleo diet when we return
we're back star talk we're talking about
uh
paleolithic pre-human
peoples and what they ate and how that
mattered in their lives and then
how did it help the birth of
civilization get back to
trinity's question about uh eating raw
versus cooked foods
um i think i read a book or knew of a
book
that said that cooking food meant you
didn't have to chew your meat as
long that's absolutely true you break
the the proteins in the meat are getting
broken up already
during cooking so you get more out of
your steak if you don't
eat it raw but if you eat it well done
if you break the proteins
does that change their nutritional value
to you it just it i think it just makes
it easier accessible for your body so
you can use
more of the energy you can use more of
the energy and you get the energy in
your body faster
so that you can spend less time chewing
and more time inventing calculus for
example
for okay so that that also does cover
cody klabuski's question to an extent
which is what change did the addition of
cooked meat
make in the diets of early hominids so
specifically the meat the meat
yes there we go so i but so i think meat
as i said earlier i tried to really
pinpoint down which
taxa would eat meat and when they would
start and what
effect that says on evolution basically
but i think about two and
right now we think about two and a half
million years ago that's
um without the ability of controlled
fire
meat was already part of the of the diet
but then roughly 1.9 million years ago a
dramatic change began to occur
in in early hominine bodies so um they
grew larger the brains increased a lot
in size and complexity
and they had adaptation for long
distance running and a long time it was
thought that just
because they had more access to meat
they had the
the resources basically the energy to do
all this
but new studies suggest actually that
they had
control of fire during that time so they
were able to cook this meat so
it doesn't mean they wouldn't eat more
meat but it also means they would cook
the meat and get more out of it
basically
so here's an interesting thought i think
all right
so right you can't cook meat until you
harness fire so
who had the idea when they see
a burning bush and say let me put my
meat in that
and then eat it that this is a this is a
brave person
but i think i would think it would
happen more like you have a wildfire
and a day later you go back through it
and you find a burned above it a
burned antelope or something and then
you would be like huh that smells tasty
that's what i could imagine i that's not
my expertise but that's
sure that's got to be how it happened
because otherwise you can't get close
enough to the fire to think that
anything good is gonna
happen by you interacting with it but
you're right i'm hungry
and there's a and the antelope is there
and i'm hungry
and it's like yum yum let's do this
again
very very cool matt give me another
question
all right and this one i'm guessing is a
parent who's trying to get
uh kids to eat because it's from having
abraham and the question is hey neil and
tina
is there any evidence of condiments
being used by our early ancestors
can't imagine the fuss created by the
young ones to eat raw veggies and
wow i love that yeah that's definitely
what's the invention of sauce and
ketchup
yeah give it to me what do you have salt
pepper what happens
as far as i know condiments are not
really known in
our early ancestors i i can't imagine
that happened like any time
super early um one early condiment i can
think of is garum
so it's produced by crushing the innards
of fish and then you ferment them with
salt and that enhances your flavor
like you have glutamic acid basically
and it hinges the flavor of your
of your given food and that was already
used by like the
romans but i think only the the elites
so if you're super rich you could afford
this and you would
have your food with it okay so romans
are like yesterday
on your time so it's easy to extrapolate
backwards and say no
nobody had ketchup or anything like that
i don't i can't imagine but then again
there might be just the evidence might
be not there it doesn't mean it's not
present i just we just haven't found it
so i as i say the
farther you go back in time so more
difficult it will be to find like
this one mustard seed that's older than
3000 years or something
yeah it could it might have just started
out where they just put different
you know foods have different flavors
and then you realize
if you use one to help change the flavor
of another one that can make a whole new
kind of dish
it could just be uh the food ended up
touching itself on the plate
hey that's better together rather than
yeah yeah because you know kids hate
that yeah
would would salt be would you be able to
detect any salt in someone's diet
would there be more sodium or chlorine
in their bones or
because we'd naturally have salt in us
anyway we would yes we have quite a lot
of salt
um and of course we know salt has been
used like for fermentation
and for um preservation preservation
there's a word thank you
um i wouldn't know if you would find it
in your in your bones basically and as i
said bones are difficult because they're
so porous so they
change during the time of fossilization
so it's always difficult to find
anything like this out of out of really
old fossils basically
so what about vitamins obviously
vitamins are a modern understanding of
the needs in our foods
but paleo people obviously knew nothing
of vitamins
yet so back to the previous question if
we know certain vitamins come to us from
vegetables and little children hate
vegetables
no reason why those children would love
it and ours hated i'm guessing they
hated vegetables too
but they needed it for their own health
do you have any insights into the role
of vitamins back then
i'm not sure about this so i i think so
i picture
the kids of early hominins like chimps
or something today and as you said they
want the
tasty fruit that has lots of sugar and
not the boring
plant with a vegetable with the vitamix
or something
but i think what we lost over time a
little bit is like the
sometimes you have a craving and then
you really want i don't know
a red pepper or something like this so i
think your body
instantly often feels what it's lacking
and so you have it in the in the wild
too with animals of
of yeah some some birds suddenly eating
salt or something because they really
need it
so i think this natural instinct might
have been more
present in um in early hominins and then
possibly they would
not hate it that much there's a youtube
video
of goats mountain goats ascending the
side of a dam
because the minerals in the rocks are
high in salt
and they they and this ascending and
it's really really steep
and they go up there they start licking
it and it was like dude
just go to the local store you know i'm
glad we have civilization
we'd be some dead humans attempting
attempting
but it's about the challenge it's about
the the joy of getting up there oh
that's what they're telling each other
that's what you're you're sure about
that man come on tim let's go up there
and lick something
so matt give me another one okay so this
one comes from dave armstrong
and says let's say we have a close shave
on changing our planet and we actually
live through it it's a relatively
pessimistic view but plausible
uh what diet changes should we be making
to prepare for climate change including
agricultural processes
and systems what diets sustained our
ancestors through tough times and what
could we do
to systemize them that for possible
climate
yeah so tina you could be the number one
source of insight that we can get when
our world becomes so bad that either the
animals go away or the crops go away and
you'll say well back
you know lucy the australopithecus she
did this so why don't we do that
well but she didn't make it so let's do
it different than lucy
okay yeah i really like this question
it's a tough one but
it's cool it's interesting because
people usually think
that we are such a successful species so
nothing can really happen at us
but if you think about it lucy and our
whole taxa and his whole species
and all of our other ancestors sooner or
later went extinct so they did not make
it
so it's interesting if we think about
the current climate change and what that
brings with us it's much faster
than what usually happened in the paleo
record um
so it will happen or it already starts
to happen super quick for different
reasons of course mostly from us and
used
and um it will be soon it might be
hotter
on our planet than it has ever been
doing early hominin times
basically so it will be new challenges
but so far i think what
brought us through it is flexibility i
only just
figured out what you meant when you said
lucy the australopithecus
didn't make it what you meant was that
that
entire hominid line didn't make it
because if they did they'd still be we'd
have australopithecus living next door
right exactly yeah if they if they made
it so whatever it was they were doing
with their environment they went extinct
yes and they just adapted in a different
way
and one of the most keys of success for
our species is
thought to be the high flexibility so we
were able to
survive stone age survive ice ages for
example and cold climate and warm
climate and wet and dry climates and
everything because
also due to our big brains we were able
to adapt to different
environmental pressures basically and i
think we take this now to a totally
different level so if you think about
adaptation or if i think about
adaptation i think about
a different size of a jaw and longer
legs or something like this but if you
think about it today
we build greenhouses we ship water like
we
transfer water from a to b to water some
some crops
we i don't know even shoot particles in
the sky to
to introduce rain for example and stuff
like this so we
alter our um our environment
to fit us to fit us basically but that
of course will only go to one
extent at some point i think it will all
be too bad
is it true that you find humans in more
diverse
other than some small bacteria perhaps
uh you find humans in more diverse
environments than any other animal yes i
think so i think so i mean we have we
be and we are all like we all look quite
still
alike right we should all be adapted to
one ecosystem but we make clothes
um and we we eat different diets
possibly if we live in different um
regions to like for example to get more
vitamin d if there's no sun around and
stuff like this
so we inhabit every corner of this earth
basically and no other species really
is able to do that well this also
dovetails quite neatly into the final
question which is act
from agastaya suresh says i've seen homo
sapiens referred to as the childs of the
ice age
if we were shaped in that extreme
climate what kind of evolutionary
adaptations could we expect in the
future
given extreme climate change so
actually thinking about the ice age it's
the climate is not even that extreme so
what happens during a cold phase there
is so much
water gets bound on the on the on the
northern
hemisphere basically you have like
kilometer thick ice
um stacks and um but it binds so much
water that yes it is colder but it's
also very dry
so you don't have this horrible icy rain
that i would hate so much that you even
with the
modern clothing you can't really shelter
from so you have dry
cold environments and during this time
for example the the
you're telling me that the the famous
joke about
um yeah i visited hell it was hot but
it was a dry heat so now you're telling
me
i say it was cold but it was a dry cold
which is much better which did you ever
wait for the bus or something for ten
minutes yeah
okay that's true i've definitely been
warmer coming off a ski slope and just
sitting in the sun having a beer than i
have
back in england okay so when the ancient
so when cave members waiting for a bus
they would have preferred dry
cold water okay and what's really
interesting there during that time
you have actually a similar in in europe
you had mammoth you had um wooly rayno's
and lions and hyenas so you have a
different fauna
than you would have in in in africa in
the savannas
so people actually early humans
migrating
found a setting they could actually work
with
and slowly adapt to basically okay so
you're talking about adaption because
we're smart and we can figure out how to
shape an environment
you're not talking about an evolutionary
and
an evolution evolutionarily adaptive
aspect of us correct i mean
you know we can adapt because like we
can put on a coat
but if i think part of that question
might have been
is there something in our evolutionary
future
i think what would have to happen is the
climate change would kill half the
population and whoever survives
their bodies are just fine with it right
i mean that's how evolution works
can you force over millions of years so
i think what we're feeling
right now would be really is really
quick basically and i think there
the expansion of our brain and our
intelligence is what
hopefully will save us from this so i of
course the humans are also morphology
still evolving we do change our gut
system change to different
yeah this lactose intolerance for
example is a super new trait basically
and so we do evolve we do change um
i don't think that if the climate gets
harder by
two degrees celsius very quick that
suddenly we will all
adapt to that in a way of having sales
we can
i don't know um evaporate our sweat
better or something i don't really
that happen in the time frames we are
looking at
except if we have control over the
genome then we play
god right and and we make whatever
change we want oh god yes
ah that's good that's you know i want
six fingers so i can play
the piano with you know play more keys
on the piano
just more complex yeah exactly exactly
see that that's in the possibly
we'll have to bring you back and comment
on that when that happens
okay we actually have to yeah can you
extract uh nitrogen isotopes from pianos
if they ate meat
that's right the carnivorous piano
the famous carnivorous piano way back
from the year 2050.
um uh tina we have to call it quits
there but
i think that's a little better than i
began
great to have you on uh this is a path
of expertise
like who even thought that we have
experts running around who think about
this sort of thing
and it's great to have you and get a
little slice of what your world is
and that's and so matt always good to
have you man
oh it's lovely to be here thanks okay
and it's science
sometimes probably probably science
that's the podcast probably science
podcast and i was delighted to have been
a guest on your show
and invite me again we'll do it again oh
that's fantastic
excellent so we got to call it quits
there i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
and always i did keep
you